how important was it to get here and
walk this carpet for tonight and it's
very important um I don't it never felt
like work I don't think I think the
workers
you know
um
all the off-camera stuff I suppose I
mean I mean the whole thing was was uh
when you're doing something you love to
do
um it's not work right and then get a
dude share it with your friends and and
getting into the only scary part of it
for me was was the accident and them
postponing the show said work so dang
hard to get it to come out
the timely manner that was going to come
and uh it was a little bit frustrating
uh telling dizzy I'm gonna be fine don't
worry about it I mean I'll be standing
I'll be walking that carpet don't you
worry about it I'll do it don't push
until next year the whole thing because
uh because a lot it was a lot of my
recovery was
was based on on this show and setting
the intention to for me to be upright
and walking and out of the bed
um for this show uh obviously for my
daughter
um and it affected so many people in my
family my friends and the show is a
great representation of that and so it
was the work was making sure that it was
going to come out on time and
um and here I am I'm standing and making
it happen so here we go I'm very excited
about it man it is a beautiful beautiful
project and what you're doing is
important where the hell do you keep all
those trucks and but more importantly
what does it mean to you now and and
like you said to get here and walk this
how is that feeling when you turned that
corner and you walked onto that carpet
yeah it's gratifying it's
it's uh cements more that that that that
self-belief is really really important
and that's how send out dreams are
manifested if it's how they that's how
they come true right because you get you
find ways to get it done and
um from buying the first fire truck to
to where I'm standing now is uh
everyone's in on the in my mind the joke
of it all I was like oh my goodness I
just bought a fire truck and made it
this kid's birthday rig right and then
it's turned into a much bigger event and
it's great to share that right and
that's that's what I like in life it's
like I'm sharing this with so many
people and that that is the real uh
Glory of this for me personally well
it's rooting for you man great to see
you yeah yeah it's good to be back man
that's for sure
[Music]
foreign